hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast clinical implementation
of pharmacogenomics delivering genomics
to the bedside presented by market Anand
Berger director pharmacogenomics at
Northshore University Health System I'm
Alexis Krause of laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's labret
is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your question into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Dunn and Berger I will now turn the
presentation over to him
thank you for joining me this afternoon
to discuss clinical implementation of
pharmacogenomics
delivering genomics to the bedside
throughout this presentation we're going
to discuss key elements to implementing
pharmacogenomics and how we take this a
laboratory based science and deliver it
to improve patient care at the bedside
for
disclosures I've received honorariums
from at Mara Health please note no
material in this presentation addresses
the services or products that America
provides
objectives by the end of the
presentation today you should be able to
define pharmacopoeia makes in related
terms you should be able to list gene
drug pairs ready for clinical
implementation and describe components
of a clinical pharmacogenomics program
in essence you should be able to have a
foundation to help a develop of
pharmacogenomics program of your own
I'll describe the health system that I
work at as I will use this as an example
and a number of points I'm going to make
today so North Shore University Health
System is in the northern suburbs of
Chicago based in Evanston and going up
basically to the Wisconsin border it's
probably a health system very similar to
a number of people in the audience it's
a for
community hospital system with about 800
beds
importantly we have a Medical Group of
that is over a hundred offices and these
two are both inpatient and outpatient
are integrated together in the safe a
local record we have about forty
thousand admissions in here any given
year and a little over a hundred and
twenty thousand Edie visits in the year
again as I've pointed out we have an
integrated electronic health care record
and we've had that for over ten years
now since about 2002 2001
but it's let's jump into some
definitions so pharmacogenomics and I
will interchange pharmacogenetics and
for the purposes presentation you can
think about this turn
interchangeably but it's basically how
changes in your DNA affect the way
you're going to respond to medication we
think about what changes we're talking
about we're talking about changes in the
area of pharmacokinetics or what your
body does to the drug think about drug
metabolizing enzymes of drug
transporters these would be cytochrome
p450 enzymes and different solute
transporters additionally we may talk
about pharmacodynamic
variation which would be what the drug
does to your body you might think about
this as immune responses with genes such
as H only B as well as drug targets such
as
OPR m1 in the mute opioid receptor
another key distinction to be made here
is the difference between germline and
somatic variation so germline variation
the variation that you inherit from your
mom and your dad it's what you transmit
to your offspring these variants can be
helpful in predicting pharmacokinetic
and pharmacodynamic
effects think about this as this is the
stuff that we're testing we can look at
the DNA in your blood through your white
blood cells the blood sample or a cheek
swab and know that that DNA is the same
DNA that's present in your liver where a
number of these pharmacodynamic
properties and pharmacokinetic
properties occur with the drug
metabolism this is in difference to
somatic variation and these are not
inherited these are ones we typically
think about related to tumors so it's
variation collected over time this can
be really helpful in predicting
pharmacodynamic effects of certain drugs
we think about
tyrosine kinase inhibitors and different
tumors gaining mutation that makes them
not susceptible to different tyrosine
kinase inhibitors so for this
presentation were mainly going to focus
on germline variants and not somatic
variants somatic variants is covered too
heavily in the oncology space so this is
thinking outside of that so variation
that you're inherited from your mom and
your dad variation then if you test it
when you were born and you test it when
you were when you die if you use the
same technique you're going to get the
same answer so that allows us to do some
very interesting things which we'll talk
about
so what does pharmacogenomics look like
in practice just on an abstract level so
here we see a group of blue people and
this is basically representing patients
of any given disease these might be
males who are between the age of 60 to
70 have a family history of coronary
artery disease and they're going in to
see their cardiologist the cardiologist
recognizes that their LDL is high and
their HDL as well so they look about the
same we're going to prescribe them and
when we give them the statin that group
what one solid block of patients
actually turns out to be three or four
different blocks of patients we have the
patients represented in green here these
are the ones that have little to no
toxicity and get the benefit of drugs
but one for the drug we do what we
expected them to do now we have the
patients in gray here these are the ones
that get no therapeutic benefit from the
medication so if we gave them a statin
we would have them come back in and we
would see that their cholesterol numbers
did not change at all we have patients
in the red here these are the patients
that have adverse events toxicities so
maybe the patient in that follow-up
visit who complains of muscle pain
associated with their statin these
patients become a huge challenge because
we have to treat both their toxicity and
then potentially find am uneffective and
alternative effective therapy that can
provide the healthcare benefits that we
were looking for with the original
prescribing we probably a fourth group
which I haven't included on the slide
which is the combination of the gray and
the red so the worst of both worlds
getting no benefit whatsoever and having
toxicity needless to say those last
three groups the drug we chose the first
time was not the optimal on drug for
them if we can do genetic testing before
we give patients that medication that
blue group now begins to look a little
bit different we're able to identify
patients who are likely at a chance of
having a sub optimal response to those
medications so what do we do if we're
able to identify these patients well we
have the green group that the same group
is before they're going to get that
standard therapy the medication we were
thinking about giving them originally
you know the go-to medication that a
prescriber things about every time they
see a patient that meets those clinical
criteria
for everybody else we can choose an
alternative therapy and so that may be a
dose adjustment or maybe choosing
another medication if I'm thinking about
the statin drug class I have five or six
options that are commonly used today
that we might choose between one of
those maybe the better agent for the
patient depending on their
men their genetic makeup and so we're
not talking about going from first line
to last line therapy we're talking about
choosing amongst therapeutic equals so
this pharmacogenomics and
pharmacogenetics and applying it to
patient care today is not about creating
new challenges for clinicians to tackle
but instead deliver new data for them to
conquer those challenges they're already
seen in practice today
practitioners today are already dealing
with this dealing with this genetic
variation they just don't know about it
and now we're giving them data to
highlight and elucidate this might
explain what they've seen for so long in
the practice if we do this appropriately
we're going to derive safer more
effective drug therapy I think everybody
can agree that's a great thing we can
also increase drug adherence and one of
the things that we know is black and
white in medicine is if a patient
doesn't take a medication it's never
going to be able to help them so
anything we can do to increase adherence
shouldn't lead to better healthcare
outcomes the main role for pharmacists
to do a number of interventions to
increase on compliance we know for a
number of these days like heart failure
if patients take their medications we
can decrease hospitalizations decrease
hospitalizations will then lead to
decrease healthcare costs across the
system so here we take the concept of
precision individualized medicine and
really begin to see the value of it on a
population health level this is a really
interesting intersection of two major
phenomenons going on in healthcare today
personalized medicine precision medicine
and population halton really makes
pharmacogenomics right for
implementation today
so it's kind of a theoretical of how we
would do it now one of the steps that it
actually takes to get it done well to
translate laboratory data to patient
care we have to go through a genotype
mechanism so this is looking at specific
places in the DNA and actually getting
the base pair changes and the
pharmacogenomics world which is
different than most of other genetics we
translate those into haplotypes
recognized in the star allele
nomenclatures you see a star one star
two star three this presents one half of
what you inherit whether it's from your
mom or your dad then we put that
together in a difficulty that's where we
combine what you get from your mom your
dad so you've described occasion as star
1 star 1 star 1 star 2 star 2 star 2 so
I'm going to stop and pose a question to
you so who in the audience knows what to
D six star five star five means
many of you guys are going to have no
idea what what that actually means and
that's really the challenge that we have
right most clinicians don't understand
star little milk lecture so we have to
translate that one step further to a
phenotype and if I begin to tell you
that a patient who is a 2d six star 4
star 5 it has the phenotype of a sip 2d6
poor metabolizer now you're beginning to
get some meaning with that right we can
begin to understand that patients if 2d6
must not function as well as the average
patient so phenotype has some a clinical
meaningfulness behind it but we really
get our main for our buck when we get to
the therapeutic recommendation when we
take that idea of a set of 2d6 poor
metabolizer and say hey you're gonna
prescribe codeine to this patient maybe
you shouldn't because they're not going
to be able to activate it in the same
way as the average patient and therefore
not get the therapeutic benefit or the
pain relieving benefits of
coding so this is the challenge that
were faced with in pharmacogenomics
we've got a lot through all these stuffs
and give people the data they need at
the moment that they need it and you can
imagine each of these steps may be
important at different points in the
patient care arena but most clinicians
really care about that therapeutic
recommendation so you've got to deliver
it in a real meaningful way
we take that on another rummel what you
see here is all the information you need
to have to make a decision about
somebody's sip 2d6 status and the drops
that are going to play a role so again
I'll pause and say who here can
understand what this means and we know
what to do in a patient care situation
immediately just from this great shot
it's write a number of you again not
quite sure what to do and you can
imagine if I gave this to the average
edy physician probably going to have no
idea what's going on and get quite
frustrated so we do it with simple
translation we turn this into a couple
of sentences and based off his patients
results
they're likely to have therapeutic
failure from
paxil and therefore we should consider
alternative therapies for depression
again we get this idea of choosing
between therapeutic equals for treating
somebody for depression we have a number
of agents we can choose between so let's
avoid the genetic problem if we can and
go to another therapeutic equal over
suggestion here with this I
need to really drive this point home
here here's a patient case to show you
where we could have used
pharmacogenomics and how we could have
used it so this is a thirteen year old
female that I saw on my clinic she came
in with her mom
the child was diagnosed with depression
and anxiety and her her mom report
numerous medication problems either
they're not working or cosmic side
effects the mom talks about every night
she has to give her daughter poison
before she goes to bed and was that
fortune she's referring to it's the
medications are using to treat
depression so obviously they're not
working it's creating a lot of unsocial
tension between the mom and the daughter
we look at the
patient's medication history you can see
here she's tried a number of common
medications so we have citalopram
sertraline
boxing teen ever peppers on that vaccine
in the middle column this is how it
helped with her depression so the red X
represents no benefit whatsoever
the yellow axes maybe there was a
benefit but not completely resolved and
then over on the side effects side the
green checkmark representing no side
effects and the red X is representing
intolerable side effects so you can see
that for all five of these medications
the tried over the last 18 months they
haven't quite worked having gone green
checks across the board so this is the
challenge that I face in my clinic
so in our pharmacogenomics clinic at
Northshore we do multi gene pal and the
reason we do is multi gene panel
we can Tesla's patient wants and get a
number of answers that may be helpful in
that patient's life throughout their
care remember for germline genetics the
pharmacogenomics that we're talking
about here if we do the test once and
then we repeat it later on and we do the
exact same test we're going to get the
exact same answer because it's DNA isn't
changing over time so we have a multi
gene panel for any given clinician Ragab
the highlight which ones are important
so in this particular case there are
three of the genes that are important
for the space ship so stead of 2d6
to see 19 these have to do with the
breakdown of SSRIs and some other
antidepressant and then SLC 64 this is
that presynaptic serotonin transporter
which may be helpful so you can see it's
represented by the Diplo type I told you
I'd translate those and phenotypes here
are the phenotypic translations off of
these results so a set of two t6 poor
metabolizer a to see nineteen
intermediate metabolizer and an SLC six
eight four four responder so those are
going to be four problematic phenotypes
when we look at this patient's
medications they've tried what her
genetic results told us in the
description so the key here is we didn't
have this genetic information ahead of
time because if we had we would have
known every medication we had tried so
far wasn't quite right for her so for
escitalopram
there's some genetic challenges with it
mostly related to this LC six a four
we have ineffective therapy and may
cause side effects for sertraline in the
box of me we see again an effective
therapy more likely to cause side
effects related to both how the drug is
broken down and that SLC 6a for Eric
resolved in a foxy likely to cause side
effects because she's not going to break
him down quite as well because we're to
these six dots since in the day what
were our recommendations well consider
hasn't arise so still selective
norepinephrine reuptake inhibitors we
gave some suggestions such as drugs is
des vanilla faxing duloxetine is
appropriate
one important highlight here is far
koujun omics rarely is a crystal ball
and normally doesn't lead to a single
choice but again leads the clinician to
narrow down their therapeutic
alternatives and allow them to choose
which medication might be appropriate
so when to conclude with this patient
case with our recommendations the
clinician immediately went to try the
appropriate and risperidone but it
failed and so that took them a month to
figure I was going to fail and then we
went on to the next recommendation this
patient is now stable on duloxetine
in La Raza don't
anybody want to guess why this patient
tried you probably on first this was the
clinicians decision
yeah I can see it here somebody got it
right so it was because of the cost of
Rico fee on versus duloxetine so it's
going to be really important to think
about when we're faced from the patient
it's about a patient care issue so it's
not just what are the genetics saying
but what is the whole clinical picture
say for pharmacogenomics and that's
going to be really really important that
we take the genetics integrated with the
the clinical answer so that then the day
we're not left with two different
answers a genetic answer and a clinical
answer but we have one answer and that's
going to be hospital patient care it's
the combination of clinical data and
genomic data integrated into it to make
a robust recommendation for a patient
all right so I think this is the
question everybody wants to know who do
we test for pharmacogenomics and when do
we do it
so we think about pharmacogenomics for
into matter you have to have a collision
of two different patient populations you
have to have patients who receive
high-risk medication so these are
medications that have a link to
pharmacogenomics so these are the ones
where if I know something in biogenics I
can make a recommendation and then you
have a patient population where the
genotype is actually there so the
problematic genotypes are present so we
get an overlap of those two populations
then pharmacogenomics can actually make
an impact into patient care
so let's look and see what size this two
different populations
so an audience response question here
what percent of the population has a
high-risk
pharmacogenomic very so we have five
percent twenty percent seventy seven
percent and ninety nine percent so I'll
give a minute for people to think about
this and so again the question is what
percent of population carries at least
one variant in the pharmacokinetic genes
related to pharmacogenomics it's at five
twenty seventy seven or ninety nine
percent
so for those of you who guessed ninety
nine percent you got that correct so
this means almost everybody in the
population carries in least one genetic
variant this data was calculated off of
population frequencies this is data
that's actually from my clinic we can
see in the clinic in the room world we
have a ninety eight percent of
population carrying at least one
clinically actionable variant and what's
really really exciting here is most of
the population has two three or four
variants um that are clinically
actionable so what that means is by
doing a panel test we just don't get one
answer and once we have that one answer
there's really nothing else there but we
have multiple opportunities to make a
difference in a patient's lives because
there are genetic variants and multiple
genes and this supports doing a multi
gene approach as opposed to a single
gene approach so one idea in that
population in the blue it's huge almost
everybody has a potentially clinically
significant farm code
so now let's look and see who's on
high-risk medications
so in Northshore it's about a million
drug orders in any given year in the
United States it's about 750
prescriptions actually expense um in
2013 so quite a lot if we think about
every patient has some genetic ovarian
then that means each of these
prescriptions may have had a chance for
pharmacogenomic pharmacogenomic data to
make a difference this doesn't say that
all
750 million
corresponding to patients with the same
pharmacogenomic variants it's not that
all these could have made a difference
but they had the potential food
there's a group called C pink or the
clinical pharmacogenomics implementation
consortium that writes guidelines to
help clinicians understand how to use
genomic data if we have it so this group
is a group of experts from across that
moral and we work to write those
guidelines not answering the question
when should you test it but instead
answering how should you use genomic
data if you have it the idea there is we
tell you how to use it you clinicians
should be able to best figure out how to
implement it into their clinical
workflows so we look at common drug-gene
pairs where C pick has seen that the
evidence is high enough to implement
into patient care
we can see that there are drug gene
pairs that's banned patient care all
across the place so we have TPMT and
thiopurines and an adult population you
might see this in rheumatological
disorders and pediatric population you
might see this in acute lymphocytic
leukemia so cancer to Rheumatology
clopidogrel on to C 19 that's going to
be in the cardiology world you'll see a
number of things here related to
psychiatry with phenytoin with the SSRIs
probably one of the most common
medications prescribed in my institution
on dance-a-tron it's in the upper right
hand corner you can see then the
drug-gene pairs are complemented by the
red and grey guys again if you remember
earlier in the presentation red is
likely to have adverse events gray is
likely that ineffective therapy and when
both are present then we find out both
ends of the spectrum so what we know
about the genomics changes a little bit
depending on the drug gene pair
I'll give you guys a minute to review
the slide and pick out your favorite arm
joint gene pair to do a little bit more
research on future
talked about a number of drugs that are
going to be really very important we've
talked about that most patients have
pharmacogenomics so in theory you could
test everyone but then the question
becomes when do we test them do we take
a pre act preemptive approach or a
reactive approach so to give you some
descriptions about what we mean this is
not a one or the other they're actually
a helmets spectra but you can go from
preemptive all the way on the left and
gradually go all the way to the riot II
get reacted so the most preemptive
approach that you could have is going to
be a healthy patient who's on no
medications
testing them with a multi gene panel
because they're interested in care and
so for this the value of this particular
test is going to be in the future in
every therapeutic decision where
pharmacogenomics may play a role in the
future this type of testing has the most
potential value in this clinical setting
and looking at it in these terms we move
a little bit more to reactive we have a
patient who is starting an
antidepressant therapy and we're going
to test them for a multi gene panel so
for that antidepressant therapy this
panel is reactive right we're waiting
till we have needed medication and then
we're going to test it but for
everything else in the multi gene panel
it becomes pre-emptive we have that data
available for this patient's care at
some point in the future
moving a little bit more reactive we
have a patient getting ready to start a
backup here we're going to test them for
a single genetic variant hla-b 5701 as
we move over a little bit further to the
most reactive we have a patient's felt
every known therapy for a disease and
they're being tested to help explain why
that happened and so as we think about
the value of this well it's not how
we're going to use as pharmacogenomic
data to make a new intervention right
we've tried every therapy that's out
there pharmacogenomics isn't going to
tell us something new but what it might
do is add personal value to this patient
it may be able to explain to them why
they fail some of those previous
therapies so that they and what is
better going on in their care so you can
see on these spectrums of pre-emptive on
one side versus reactive on the other
they both can be valuable to a patient
but the ways in which we measure the
value will have to be different it's
going to be really important as you set
up a program that if you are looking at
clinical endpoints or the different
outcomes you're going to look at that
your testing approach matches where
you're going to find value it's going to
be incredibly important so we take that
pre-emptive look where we have the most
potential clinical value because we know
that patients regardless of their
conditions may receive for high-risk
pharmacogenomic drugs from the previous
slide and we know that patients are
likely to have at least one genetic
variant from another previous slide
let's go to the next level and say okay
can we predict what percent of patients
are going to receive a high-risk
medication um for the first time over
any given four year P
so this is a study that was published a
few years ago and they looked at
prescription claims data and you can see
represented over here in the red that if
you're a Medicare age there's a 50%
chance that you're going to receive a
new prescription for a high-risk
pharmacogenomic medication over any 40
year time period so that's incredible a
coin flip on chance of getting a high
risk mitigation so this means that most
of your patients are going to get are
going to benefit from pharmacogenomics
if you do testing if they're over a
certain age so 40 and above so now we're
beginning to hone in on what patient
population we should do this type of
pre-emptive testing there are a couple
of key points about less so one is it's
a high risk medication for the first
time your patient being on a high-risk
medication may not be a reason to do
pharmacogenomic testing in fact if your
patients been on a medication for more
than six months I probably don't care
about their genetics because they've
already told me what their phenotype is
they're already telling me whether that
medication is working whether they're
having affects those types of things and
so genetics doesn't really impact that
patient care delivery in that setting
however we get it ahead of time before
they have exposure to medication we can
then make a change and then over a four
year time period that's going to be
really important because that gives you
an idea of how long do we have to
measure the outcomes that see the
benefit for a particular patient if you
have an implementation where you're only
gonna measure outcomes for a year well
it's going to get a little tough to make
sure that a large percentage of your
population sees a high-risk medication
but if you do it four to five year study
well now we're getting pretty good
numbers into seeing the benefits of our
culture so as you're evaluating the
impact of your program it's important to
keep these numbers
so now I'm going to discuss what this
looks like in practice and how we've
done this ignore short
so some key components for a
pharmacogenomics program are represented
in this diagram so that big blue oval
that is the pharmacogenomics program
we've got five different components so
we have to come up with genetic testing
we have to collect that information
that's the genetic database we have to
link that to some kind of knowledge base
or clinical decision support tool which
is represented here as CBS and then you
have to deliver that to the end user
when the end user is patients or
providers you can see that here as a
chart an event of the day education
becomes incredibly important as we do
pharmacogenomics so let's hone in on
genetic Testament how we get that done
or short
so in North Shore we have a dedicated
pharmacogenomics clinic this clinic was
first started in March of 2015 and we
started it because our patients wanted
to use pharmacogenomics in their care
you really weren't sure what that meant
and our providers wanted to use it in
their patient care even though they
didn't know what were the best ways to
do that and so we set this visit up over
we set this clinic up over two different
visits and so the first visit was really
important for to highlight the benefits
limitations risk and cost of testing for
a given patient so this way they know
when they're not going to get they know
what they're going to get they know how
much it's going to cost them and they
can make a value-based decision on
whether pharmacogenomics is right and
their care it's really important to have
realistic expectations about what
pharmacogenomics is going as I said
earlier this is not a crystal ball it's
not going to explain every response
inanimate occasion it's not going to
give us that one answer that's going to
solve all of their problems but it's a
piece of clinical data that could be
integrated into the rest of their care
so really important to have those
realizing expectations there's a lot of
misinformation out there we found this
visit to be really really important in
fact it almost took an hour to begin
with to get this going once patients
decided to go forward with testing we
would test them in that first visit and
we would have them come back for a
second visit to fully explain their
results and really answer any questions
they had about the clinical clinical
meaningfulness of their form with our
genomic results um
patients found this one to be very very
rewarding at the end of this we were
able to take these results and then
share them with other providers based on
patients being willing to share this
data with their other providers you can
imagine that this approach isn't very
salable right I can only see so many
patients in my clinic on every day and
if pharmacogenomics should be beneficial
to every patient we've got to figure out
better ways of testing them than having
them come to the clinic and getting this
all out of the way there so what we did
is we created this at-home testing kit
it's similar to a number of other
third-party vendors where it's a cheek
swab so or a saliva sample depending on
which tests you use and in our case it's
a cheek swabs you take a really long
tube tip basically in rubbing against
inside of your cheek for a minute and
that collects enough DNA for us to do
the analysis along with us at home
testing kit was important to set up
those release expectations so we
developed a four minute video to talk
about the risk benefits limitation for
the patient once we were able to do that
get patients testing at home this
allowed more access points to
pharmacogenomics in the Northshore
system
incredibly important we were able to
exponentially grow the number of
patients being tested any given day and
Northshore while still ensuring they
have realistic expectations of what's
going to happen with their testing so
figuring out a mechanism around this in
your healthcare system could be crucial
to the success of a pharmacogenomics
program once we have this data we then
had to deliver it to the provider so
we're talking about that area in the
blue here
so at Northshore our data flow is we
have mini ins which represent on left
side they go to a genomic repository
that genomic repository is where we
standardize everything we link it up
with a knowledge base and then we push
it out into a number of different
components including electronic medical
record and additional application such
as a pharmacogenomics profile this
approach allows us to meet the mini
needs of providers without knowing the
specific need that they're going to use
because they have a multi-modal approach
and they can find out which one works
best for them
it was important while we were doing
this to recognize that there are two
different levels of clinical
interactions with pharmacogenomics and
based on these different levels we
probably needed to develop different
delivery mechanisms
so we have the highest risk drug
profiles and so these are the ones where
the genetics suggest that getting even
one or two doses of this medication may
be detrimental to the patient and we
need to do something immediately the
greatest example I have there is to see
19 poor metabolizers in Kolkata girl so
in the setting of high-risk acute
coronary syndrome patients may be
stented that stent have the possibility
of being closed or mean from boasting
because platelets will aggregate to the
outside of the stent you give a patient
clip integral to prevent that
aggregation of platelets the platelets
aggregate closes on the stand the
patient hasn't a heart attack that can
only lead to their demise want to avoid
that well in poor metabolizer patients
they cannot activate clopidogrel as the
average patient so if you gave them poor
metabolizer petr l it's like giving them
a placebo so increasing their risk of
death that's definitely something we
want to try to avoid and it's going to
be this high risk profile and you'll
notice that Northshore most patients
don't have
high risk drug interactions and so this
gives us some flexibility as to how we
might want to deliver to patients they
are do providers maybe as an
interruptive alert and it's going to be
really important to show you like a
second when we compare that to medium
risk interactions and so these are ones
where knowing the genomics is really can
be helpful to the patient and provider
and if you look at these two graphs what
you'll notice is the number of cautions
per patient in this medium risk is much
greater than in the high risk and so
we're talking about 15 to 25
interactions for most patients and I'll
give you an example when this
interaction looks like so let's say this
is OPR m14 responders to opioid so this
says these patients may need higher
doses of opioids than other then the
provider might otherwise expect based
off the clinical picture and so if a
provider was having to deal with 15 to
25 interruptive alerts per patient
they're going to get burned out really
really quickly and so based off of these
risk profiles we needed to develop two
different mechanisms for delivering this
information to providers but still being
able to deliver to them in useful ways
and so for those high-risk ones where
most patients don't have the
profile to trigger anything we thought
interruptive alerts would be a great way
of doing that so you can think about
this as active CTS the system goes out
and does something here's the control
example we let this provider know that
his patients at risk and decrease
accuracy we suggest using an alternative
agent and we set them up to remove an
existing order and put on a new order
this would interrupt their workload to
help prevent that catastrophic event
from happening
but for those other events that passive
CBS we've actually created a
pharmacogenomics profile we use a third
party company which you can see in the
screenshot called hack axe to help us
deliver this to the far to the
medication profile for the patient so as
the provider is in the portal or in
their electronic medical record they can
click on this portal and they'll see an
alphabetical list of medications that
are a problem for the patient one of the
problem is and then finally the genetics
and so this profile is really
interesting because we're meeting the
provider where they need to be we're
giving them this data from the drug
point of view that thing they're most
familiar with as opposed to lead it out
with it genetics because we found out
that genetics they're really not
comfortable with it and so we wanted to
avoid the genetics where we can and get
them to that thing that they understand
best the drugs so this profile allows us
to do this and patients will have 20 to
30 medications on these profiles and it
does bring up the question of are there
better ways to do this and even that's
drug profile we're going to see what
that goes in the future
alright and so the last component that
we're going to talk about is going to be
education education is incredibly
important for pharmacogenomics and what
is that education look like well it's
the clinical knowledge it's the
educating about why pharmacogenomics is
important what are the drug-gene pairs
or pharmacogenomic matters what is
testing interpretation look like so when
they get a poor metabolizer phenotype
what can they extrapolate that to and
that's also understanding the ethical
legal and social issues associated with
pharmacogenomics so then any provider
that a patient season or short is
empowered to answer questions and meet
the needs of the patient regardless of
what's going on but in addition to that
it's the operational knowledge it's how
to use the tools that we've developed so
far
teaching them how to order a
pharmacogenomics panel how to look at
the profile how to respond jewellers
where to find it in the record and a lot
of people forget about this operational
knowledge that you have to deliver to
providers because in the day I could
test patients all day long build all
these really cool tools but if nobody
knows where to find them or how to use
them we're never going to derive value
for pharmacogenomics we're never going
to drive value from that testing the
patient agreed to all right now as we
begin to wrap up I want to emphasize a
few points so this is the time line for
North Shore's pharmacogenomics program
so before I arrived in North Shore in
2014 we have a line I call the wild wild
west or pharmacogenomics at Northshore
so this is where clinicians are ordering
pharmacogenomics with little to no
support from the healthcare system so we
have no idea what was going on in this
time but we have found out through some
other patient interactions that there
were patients getting pharmacogenomic
results that had value but nobody was
acting upon the value for the results in
August 2014 around the time that I
joined we created a pharmacogenomics
subcommittee of PMT and we gave
ourselves some oversight infrastructure
that began to allow us to tackle small
projects moving towards the largest
limitation that we have today about five
months later we had created interruptive
alerts for three drug-gene pairs so we
started really small we looked at
drinking pairs where the logic behind
them were pretty simple and where the
prescribing volume is pretty low so we
could cut our teeth on the low-hanging
fruit and we got it wrong it wasn't
going to impact that the patient's as I
mentioned before in March of 2015 we
created the pharmacogenomics clinic and
again that was because we started the
support pharmacogenomics and as we
supported it more and more people became
interested in it we needed to meet that
need of our patients and providers very
important to understand their need and
go out and eat it ajan a
year later we move move to that third
party that we talked about earlier to
enhance our clinical decision support
and so we went from supporting three
drug-gene pairs in the medical record to
doing nine and
forty-five different drugs so
exponentially green while we were
supporting clinical decision support
in October of 2016 we moved in house
testing and that quickly led to in
January of 2017 hard to imagine so ver a
year ago now we had
the ability for any provider in North
Shore to order that test through the
on-demand educational video that
patients can watch online and then the
at home testing and this has allowed us
to test
many more patients than he ever could
have through the clinic so we were
ordering about 15 tests a month through
the clinic maybe 30 at the most um two
just recently in December we had ordered
a hundred and sixty tests across the
healthcare systems you can see how much
we grew so we started out small and took
a small projects on film upon them to
establish a program that it's pervasive
across healthcare system I'll show you a
couple graphs to show you how things
have changed over time
early on our departments in 2015 who
were using us what was mostly psychiatry
might ask well why was it one the best
data for the value of pharmacogenomics
is a valuable was it available in the
psyche a psychiatric population and
those were the providers that showed the
most interest so they're the ones we
went after first and then we got more
stories based on psychiatry and so more
psychiatrists it began to resonate with
them but one of the things that we found
was patients weren't getting their first
antidepressant their first antipsychotic
when they were with the psychiatrist
they actually saw got those medications
before that with their primary care
physicians and so we worked two years
later we can see that primary care is
actually our greatest utilizers of
pharmacogenomics of our short gives to
that idea that we're pushing preemptive
testing test the patient before they
have the medication test then where we
can gain most value for fall code
so next up we continue to update the
system based off new data that is found
and we're looking at the best mechanisms
around how do you keep the system up to
date and can we knew that leveraging
external resources the more work we can
get third parties to use international
consortiums like see fit the less work
we have to do in our system the more
scalable our approach we believe that
risk score based interventions becomes
incredibly important we can see that in
a number of areas such as prostate
cancer on cardiology we think some of
these risk scores may be able to move
into pharmacogenomics if we can predict
patients who are likely to get high-risk
medications before they happen and then
we believe that the genomics is just the
first omics that's going to be important
in pharmaco therapy we think proteomics
is going to be important metabolomics
already some great emerging evidence of
microbial mix becoming incredibly
important to drug response so how can we
integrate that into the system that we
have those are all challenges I'm
looking forward to for the next one year
to five to ten years
so in conclusion key takeaways for the
present for implementing
pharmacogenomics start with small
manageable projects based on your
resources knowing your resources is
incredibly important collaboration is
key
implementing pharmacogenomics is more
than just the pharmacist it's the whole
healthcare team together and it includes
individuals from a number of disciplines
so collaborating where you can
additionally we're not doing anything
new with pharmacogenomics we're just
delivering new data so a number of the
processes that you have had already
developed in your healthcare system can
be used for pharmacogenomics so identify
those and capitalize on all that work
already done and
pharmacogenetics works best if it's
integrated into the standard workflows
of your institution and your clinicians
you know don't make them come to you
meet them where they're at and if their
needs so that the valuable work you get
done can actually impact patient care
and with that I will take questions and
open the floor thank you for your
attention today
thank you dr. Don and Berger for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button will answer as
many questions as we have time for so
let's get started our first question is
what clinical area should be addressed
first when implementing pharmacogenomics
this is a great question and it's a
question has many answers unfortunately
there's not one main go-to area I think
when you're looking at which area should
you start doing pharmacogenomics
implementation at its understanding who
and your institution is supportive of
doing pharmacogenomics so that's both
supportive from the administrative
standpoint how much resources you have
available to you and also from the
clinical standpoint who's really really
interested in doing pharmacogenomics so
people get programs such as st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital one of the
areas they started with was pediatric al
why because that was a huge need at
their institution they would stream a
lot of patients with pediatric al and
that's where they had expertise so they
went after that one versus one they
understood the vets if we will get the
energy of Florida their cardiologists
were really interested in to see 19 in
clopidogrel and cardiology
pharmacogenomics so they started there
first but if we will get Northshore well
we didn't start with pediatric al
because that population didn't exist for
us we talked to the cardiologists and
they weren't sold on the clinical data
available at the time first comes from
Devlin pharmacogenomics oh we didn't go
after that but instead our psychiatrists
really interested in understanding how
do we use pharmacogenomic so we went
after them first on the clinical
implementation side but because the
genetics around depression in psychiatry
is complicated it's multiple genes we
didn't actually systematically support
that first we were supporting that
through clinical consultations and we
went after actually the therapure
earrings and TPMT from
rheumatological standpoint first because
that logic was well established and it
was an easy way of building in an epoch
i'm our electronic medical record so
make sure you took two different
approaches but identifying what
resources we had who was excited and
where we thought we could get some major
momentum and then we began to grow those
together so that we began to have
overlap between the two so it's really
important to understand where are your
resources who is available who wants to
work with you on pharmacogenomics what
patient population do you have that can
benefit from this and pick the one
that's right for you unfortunately I
don't have the answer for this is the
right one to go to every time but
there's probably no one wrong answer
here there are a lot of right answers
for you to go after so thanks for that
question
our next question is what is the biggest
challenge facing your program today
um so the biggest challenge facing our
program today
today I'm not answered is one challenge
I'm gonna answer it as multiple
challenges because I think on each front
we we have different challenges so one
is we've done a lot of work in
Northshore on getting this data to the
provider and we need to better
understand how do we get this data to
the patient patients are probably the
best vehicle for disseminating this data
across one institution as well as
multiple institutions and Northshore we
have a number of patients that receive
care at multiple health systems and
those other health systems don't have
the informatics support that we have in
North Shore but those patients should
still be able to benefit from the
pharmacogenomic testing that we have
done and so we have to figure out how do
we deliver this data to patients in a
way in which they can understand it in a
way which they can understand it and
then educate their other providers about
it so we're trying to figure out what
that looks like it's probably a patient
based portal on patient facing portal
with a lot of information
another challenge that we have is as
we've developed pharmacogenomics other
genomics have become important so a
retic Airy cancer genomics risk for
cardiomyopathy sudden cardiac death
that's becoming an area of interest at
our healthcare system so we're trying to
understand how do we integrate all of
that so that clinicians have one genomic
place to go as opposed to having a place
to go for this genomic or that genomics
or those genomics because we think if we
do that ultimately they're going to lose
interest in genomics and that brings me
to the third challenge that we're facing
today
that's going to be keeping up interest
in pharmacogenomics for those providers
who have not already adopted
pharmacogenomics so when the tools are
new and shiny it's pretty easy to
people's attention but you can see it
with any implementation not just
pharmacogenomics over time clinicians a
number of them lose interest and stop
using the tools a YouthBuild once you
have to go in and do the education in
addition to doing that re-education you
have to begin to understand why didn't
they lose interest what didn't we do
right that first time and so having a
system of
evaluating and improving and
implementing and evaluating and
improving and implementing over time
that that quality of improvement system
that we've learned so much about through
medical errors and other parts of
clinical implementation is also true
here so taking your tools and making
them better every time to meet the needs
of your provider because if you don't
need the needs of your providers why are
you doing implementation so those are
really three areas that were challenged
with today so again how do we deliver
this information to patients so it's
actually another user of our data
and also how are we going to get
providers onboard who are not already on
board so thanks for that question
and it looks like we have time for one
more class what pharmacogenetic tests do
you use in your institution
yeah so this pharmacogenomic test that
we use our institution it's a 20 gene
panel what's that about a hundred and
twenty different variants and it's a
panel that we customized for our own
institution we've run it in our in-house
laboratory and this is a good approach
for us partly because we have the
resources in the laboratory space but
when we originally started we did not
use this test we actually use some
third-party testing um it's probably a
question that I can answer there a whole
another presentation I'll spare you
those details today but
identifying a pharmacogenomic test that
meets the needs of your patients and
providers is incredibly important what I
mean by needs I mean testing the genes
and variants that are important for
whatever drugs you're going to do the
patient whatever clinical area that
you're going to implement on as well as
testing the variants that are found in
the ethnic mix of your population is
going to be important as well otherwise
you may get some erroneous answers you
can look to add warfarin
pharmacogenomics to see the importance
of testing variants that are seen in the
ethnic mix of your population um
there are a number of tests out there in
the commercial space having a thorough
way of evaluating them and making sure
they're meeting the needs of your health
system going to be incredibly important
you do this having a systematic approach
is incredibly important there are some
papers on the literature that can help
you go through this process
it's a really fundamental question you
have to answer early on again it's one
of those ones where there's multiple
answers out there for Northshore the
right idea for us was to do it ourselves
but I know for another a number of other
institutions that's not the right
approach so don't go to it because you
think it's on the best thing to do
unless you have the support to do it
there are a number of great third-party
labs out there
right thanks for that question as well
and I think that concludes today so
thank you for your attention and I look
forward to seeing you guys success in
the future with implementing
pharmacogenomics I
would like to once again thank dr. John
inverter for his presentation I would
also like to thank lab rats were making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through May of
2018 you will receive an email from
labyrinth letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye